oh
le développement de la vie nécessite
trois éléments de la lumière de la
chaleur et l'humidité la raison pour
laquelle des arbres tels que ceux ci ne
pousse pas prise au nord ne tient pas
seulement au froid mais aussi aux longs
mois sombres de l'hiver ils n'auraient
pas assez de lumière pour poursuivre
leur croissance
ici au nord de la norvège à 500 km du
cercle arctique
cette lumière est à peine suffisante et
le froid peut être extrême on enregistré
dans ces forêts des températures de
moins 70 degrés et en hiver
s'ils produisent de très fortes chutes
de mer
non seulement le froid menace de geler
la sève des arbres mais il peut menacer
leur approvisionnement en eau gelée elle
aussi de sorte qu'en hiver cette région
est en quelque sorte aussi desséché
quart d heure les pins ont la même
nécessité de stocker l'euro que les cats
c'est pourquoi leurs aiguilles sont
protégés par une peau épaisse presque
imperméable cette peau n'est pas
comestible
par contre les graines que contiennent
les cônes dépeint constitue durant
l'hiver l'une des seule nourriture
disponible dans la forêt grâce à un bec
croisé qui lie à donner son nom
c'est oiseaux à la possibilité de
séparer les écailles déconne pour en
sortir les graines les campagnols se
fraie un chemin à travers la neige pour
récolter inlassablement un maximum de
provisions la forêt hivernale ne pouvant
ainsi nourrir que quelques herbivores
les prédateurs sont aussi peu nombreux
la chouette lapone a des pattes
particulièrement longue
conçu pour allier psa 3 dans la neige
elle patrouille longuement car les
occasions de se nourrir sont plutôt
rares
le lynx à de plus vastes appétit et il
semble capable de calculer le rendement
de sa chasse de manière très précise
tout se passe comme s'ils savaient que
s'ils n'attrape pas le lièvre qu'il
convoite sur une distance de 150 mètres
et bien la quantité de viande qu'ils
obtiendraient ne serait pas suffisante
pour compenser sa dépense d'énergie
alors tout simplement le lynx abandonne
les conifères de la forêt boréale pousse
tout autour du globe
formant une ceinture de quelque vingt
mille kilomètres de long qu'on appelle
la taïga à partir de la scandinavie elle
s'étend à travers le nord de l'europe
la sibérie et jusqu'aux rives du
pacifique et plus loin en amérique du
nord
durant la dernière ère glaciaire lorsque
les mères étaient plus basses le détroit
de béring n'existait paris cette
ceinture se prolonger sans interruption
jusqu'en amérique du nord
c'est la raison pour laquelle on
retrouve aujourd'hui pratiquement les
mêmes espèces dans les régions
septentrionales d'amérique d'asie et
d'europe
mais avec l'arrivée du printemps les
forêts de chaque continent reprennent un
caractère particulier
en scandinavie la chouette épervière une
nomade qui a passé l'hiver sous des
latitudes plus hospitalières réunir au
nord à la recherche de nourriture et
d'un endroit où bâtir son lit le grand
coq de bruyère au grand tétras établi
son territoire de la norvège à la cyber
est ainsi qu un des seuls mangeurs
d'aiguillés de pin le tétras-lyre
des hiboux de différentes espèces
viennent également dans ces forêts
nordiques pour y trouver leur nourriture
il ne creuse pas l'orgie de même il
compte pour cela sur les pics noir
experts en la matière lorbek a serré
avec lequel il attrape les insectes leur
faire également de ciseaux cela étant il
préfère travailler les arbres morts dont
le bois est passablement plus tendre
l'anémone des bois est maintenant en
fleurs de même que les taxes chaque
arbre porte à la fois des fleurs mâles
et femelles qui arrive à maturité avec
un certain décalage dans le temps afin
que les fleurs femelles puissent être
fertilisé par le pollen des autres
arbres la chaleur est maintenant à son
comble les derniers visiteurs de l'été
arrive et toutes les forêts du nord
retentissent de leurs champs ce pouillot
fitis qui fit le fit vigoureusement en
scandinavie a fait un long voyage
il y a deux fils du sahara c'est
également le cas de ce trac et ils n'ont
pas voyagé pour rien ici la nourriture
abonde il y à des myriades d'assaut
cette créature dépenaillé est
difficilement reconnaissable car c'est
elle ne sont pas encore déplier en fait
c'est un papillon son premier souci est
de quitter le sol de la forêt qui
grouille de danger ils pompent ensuite
un fluide à l'intérieur de son corps
pour l'injecter dans les veines de ses
ailes afin de les déployer
ici les papillons déposent leurs voeux
afin que les chenilles puisse se nourrir
sur les jeunes pousses les fourmis des
bois qui ont raté leurs trois au sol
vont en chercher d'autres
sur les branches la couleur et la forme
des chenilles leur permettent de se
dissimuler à la vue des oiseaux par
contre elles n'ont aucune protection
contre les fourmis qui chassent à
l'odorat et au toucher
les larves de la tenthrède forme d'un
dessin sur les pousses de pain elles
peuvent faire 2 contre les fourmis une
défense chimiques en mangeant il
emmagasine une partie de la résine des
aiguilles de pin dans une poche buccale
quand une fourmi les attaques et lui
dépose sur la tête une goutte de cette
résine qui lui endommagent les yeux et
les antennes la fourmi et de l'or
complètement désorienté même si elle
retrouve le chemin de son nid elle
continuera dégage une odeur tels que les
autres fourmis la considérons comme une
intruse et la thur
le torcol fourmilier est un membre de la
famille des piques dont les fourmis
confie-t-il à 3 privilégiés comme ses
cousins le torcol fourmilier fait son
nid dans le tronc des arbres mais il ne
le croit pas lui-même il préfère
squatter reese est celui d'un autre
public
attirer en masse par la nourriture que
constituent les insectes et pour faire
reproduire beaucoup de ces oiseaux
quitteront bientôt ses bois pour fuir
les rigueurs de l'hiver qui s'annonce
certains comme le grive mauvis partiront
vers des pâturages plus au sud
le bruant quant à lui dès qu'il aura
achevé sa mue s'envolera vers des
régions planté deux autres départs vers
le sud aussi pour cette chouette
épervière menacé par le retour du froid
et donc par la fin sous sa route ce la
forêt change d'apparence orange et de
conifères sombre succèdent des arbres
aux feuilles vert tendre et fun des
frênes des êtres de boulot
oh
ici plus au sud
la température et pris 12 mai étaient
plus longs ces terres boisées sont
épargné par le gel non pas à deux ou
trois mais huit ou neuf mois dans
l'année
la forme les arbres est différente au
lieu de branches tombante ployant sous
la neige cellfish étant largement avec
d'innombrables rangée de feuilles qui
permettent de capter l'énergie abondante
du soleil
ses feuilles ils ne sont pas recouvert
d'une peau protectrice
elles ont des structures fines et
délicates contrairement aux aiguilles de
pin elles servent de nourriture apprécié
a énormément de créatures à des animaux
de grande taille comme les serres qui en
font une grande consommation mais
surtout en quantité bien plus grande
encore elles servent de nourriture à
tous les insectes
la voûte de la forêt à cette période
tardive de l'été abrite plus d'oise ou
qu'à aucun autre moment de l'année
les oiseaux migrateurs récemment arrivé
en provenance du nord et les oiseaux à
demeure qui rassemble de la nourriture
en prévision de la seconde couvet de la
saison on y observe également des
oisillons qui commence à chercher eux
mêmes leur nourriture
hésitant encore à déterminer ce qui est
comestible et ce qui ne l'est pas la
plupart d'entre eux vont à la chasse aux
insectes et la récolte est énorme
le un pro est friande et infecte qui
vivent sur les écorces comme ce sphinx
du peuplier qui essaie de se défendre en
simulant la férocité
la sittelle fait habituellement son
archet en parcourant les trop de autant
bas afin de repérer des insectes qui
auraient échappé à l'appétit du grain
pro explorant lui de base en os les plus
grands experts en la matière sont une
fois encore les piques dont le pic
épeiche est un digne représentant son
ouïe est exceptionnel ils localisent les
larves uniquement au bruit un film
qu'elles font en se déplaçant à
l'intérieur des écorces
chaque continent possède sa propre gamme
de pilleurs il en existe dix espèces en
europe et deux fois plus ici en amérique
du nord
celui ci le sap soccer ou pictures de
ses oeuvres perfore des trous dans les
arbres non pour chasser des insectes
mais pour recueillir de la scène
chaque trou est orienté vers le bas de
manière à ce que la seule ne puisse
s'écouler à l'extérieur du tronc elle à
l'intérieur où elle forme un petit
réservoir auquel se nourrit le de
5 après l'été le silence retombe sur les
forêts et les feuillages délicats
incapable de survivre aux rigueurs de
l'hiver
tantôt seule après être passé par tous
les tons de rouge et de bras finalement
la terre est saisi par le gel beaucoup
de petits mammifères ont creusé leur
trouble hiberner certains comme
l'écureuil terrestre chipmunks se
réveille de temps en temps afin de
rechercher de la nourriture ou de faire
un peu d'exercice pour se réchauffer
dans les bois américain vit le plus
spectaculaire de ce normal l'ours noir
qui sommeille pendant des mois
cette femelle ne quittera pas sa tanière
de tout l'hiver dans lequel elle
continuera cependant à réchauffer et
elle l'était c'est peut-être
dans certaines régions du sud des états
unis
les hivers sont suffisamment en paierez
pour que certains arbres à feuillage
large conserve celui ci toute l'année
ici poussent également des pins qui
paradoxalement doivent leur existence au
feu en cas d'incendié les jeunes shon
brûlant quelques mini les mauges ont
terminaux des jeunes femmes sont quant à
eux entourés d'une sorte de touffes
d'aiguilhe qui brûle a assez basses
températures le temps qu'elle se consume
le foyer principal s'est déplacé et au
bout de la tige le bourgeon à partir
duquel se développera un nouveau rameau
est un des ses feux généralement allumés
par la foudre sont de courte durée mais
ils débarrassent la forêt de ces arbres
morts le pic sait qu'il ne peut creuser
son nid en toute sécurité que dans des
pages vivant même si leur boisson si dur
qu'il devra creuser pendant deux ans
pour construire son nid
la fève résineuses sur un tas l'endroit
où la brèche a été ouverte dans l'arbre
les oiseaux perf leur trou très bas sur
le tronc là où la ferme ne coule pas et
où le bois est assez épais pour
installer un ni suffisamment vaste
l'écoulement de la résine est déviée
vers l'extérieur par le forage de kano
au dessus et au dessous de l'entrée du
nid
le nid de proches du sol
son entrée est facilement repérables car
elle est rapidement entouré d'une couche
jaune de résine coagulé le serpents
ratiers est un grand prédateur c'est un
grimpeur extrêmement adroit le fait que
l'ouverture du nid du pivert soit assez
basse est donc relativement facile à
atteindre par le serpent semblent
exposés les habitants lui ni à un danger
considérable mais la véritable fonction
de la résine va maintenant vous
apparaître
les composants chimiques de cette résine
irritent la peau du serpent et
l'obligent à s'arcbouter pour s'éloigner
litres eux jusqu'à la chute
les dégâts provoqués par les feux
peuvent souvent être constatée dans les
forêts de pins du sud et de californie
cet arbre mesure 12 mètres de large à la
base et 80 mètres de hauteur c'est un
séquoia géant que l'on estime à g de
2500 ans cet autre séquoia baptisé
général sherman est légèrement plus
grand son poids est estimé à près de 14
cents tonnes seul organisme vivant le
plus lourd au monde
on pense qu'il a entre 3500 et 4000 ans
et les séquoias se sont développés en
amérique du nord durant l'ère glaciaire
il ya 8000 ans quand la terre a commencé
à se réchauffer ils ont disparu à
l'exception de quelques groupes isolés
dans les montagnes de la sierra nevada
enneigées pendant pratiquement six mois
de l'année les conifères une grande
partie de leur prolifération à leur
capacité d'adaptation au climat
changeant du nord ils peuvent survivre
aussi bien aux jours sombres et glacé
univers qu à la chaleur et au fur
ravageur de l'été à 16 cents kilomètres
d'ici nous arrivons sous les tropiques
où le climat est radicalement différent
plus de variations véritable mais un
niveau constant de lumière de pluie et
de chaleur durant toute l'année